Mohammad is stateless.
He’s been here, in this
sprawling camp, for over a year.
He’s one of the 120,000 10 to 18-year-olds
living in the Rohingya refugee camp at the
Bangladesh-Myanmar border.
His family fled the bloody military-led massacre in Myanmar,
which killed up to 10,000 people by December
2017.
And for those who made it to the camps there’s
a real fear of Rohingya youths becoming a
lost generation.
No one is allowed officially to work.
Some people buy and sell food aid supplies, but the risks are high.
Bangladeshi authorities say it is a criminal offense.
Yet people do whatever they can to get by.
The bi-monthly food rations each family receives consists of rice, lentils and vegetable oil.
With few opportunities to learn, and fearful of returning home to Myanmar, Mohammad has
taken up whatever casual work
he could find.
The work is challenging.
Alongside his chores and the daily grind at the blacksmith workshop, Mohammad is a teen
who survived terror.
And his memories, these scars of war, are
a burden he continues to carry.
Mohammad used to collect firewood in Myanmar.
And now, in the refugee camp in Bangladesh
he supports his parents, his five sisters
and two brothers who are reliant on aid.
He is the eldest son.
His father looks for casual day work too.
Mohammad works 10 hours a day.
The long, arduous walk every morning and evening, and then standing all day to work, have taken a toll on his body.
While his future is uncertain, Mohammad still dreams of a life where he can go to school.
But for now, Mohammad is just dreaming of the day when he'll be able to go home.